MARY MILLER:
BEFORE I MOVED HERE I'VE
NEVER USED A CHAINSAW.
I COULDN'T EVEN LIFT THE
MAUL FOR SPLITTING ROUNDS.
CURLY: ALL RIGHT.
MARY MILLER:
THIS IS THE SPOT.
CURLY: YEAH, THERE IS
ONE RIGHT UP HERE THAT
I HAD PICKED OUT
FOR YA THERE.
MARY MILLER: THERE'S A LOT
OF CEDARS UP IN THERE.
CURLY: TREE FELLING IS
A VERY DANGEROUS,
DANGEROUS OCCUPATION.
YOU GOT TO REMEMBER THAT SAW
IS NOT YOUR FRIEND.
IT'S NOT GOING TO WATCH
OUT FOR YA.
LET IT GO!
MARY MILLER: AH, HOLY (BLEEP),
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THIS STUFF.
CURLY: MARY, YOU GOTTA
HAVE YOUR SAW FLAT.
MARY MILLER: ALL I COULD
THINK OF IS THAT TREE
IS COMING DOWN ON ME.
CURLY, IT WANTS TO
GO THE OTHER WAY.
IT'S STARTING TO MOVE!
CURLY: KEEP GOING,
MARY, DON'T STOP.
THAT TREE CAN BITE YOU
BACK IN A HEARTBEAT.
CUT FAST, CUT FAST,
KEEP GOING.
YOU MIGHT NOT LIVE TO
TELL THE STORY.
DON'T STOP, COME ON,
COME ON.
MARY MILLER: I AM NOT READY
FOR WINTER AT ALL.
THINGS GO IN THREES, AND WE
HAD THREE EASY WINTERS,
SO I THINK THIS YEAR WE'RE
GONNA GET SLAMMED.
NARRATOR: FOR THE PEOPLE
OF SOUTHEAST ALASKA,
THE KEYS TO THEIR FUTURE
OFTEN LIE IN THE
LESSONS OF THEIR
PIONEERING PAST.
FOR SEVEN YEAR RESIDENT,
MARY MILLER,
SURVIVING THE LONG ALASKAN
WINTER REQUIRES
PLANNING FOR THE FUTURE.
TODAY, THIS MEANS STOCKING
UP ON FIREWOOD.
MARY MILLER: I'M NOT COMFORTABLE
WITH WHAT I HAVE HERE.
IT'S DEFINITELY NOT GONNA GET
ME THROUGH THE WINTER.
NARRATOR: TO GATHER A
SUFFICIENT SUPPLY REQUIRES
MARY TO ADD A FUNDAMENTAL
BUT PARTICULARLY RISKY
SKILL TO HER ARSENAL
OF TALENTS.
MARY MILLER: I PURCHASED A
NEW CHAINSAW THIS SUMMER
BUT I'VE ACTUALLY NEVER
CUT A TREE DOWN.
AND, UH, I WANT TO BE
ABLE TO DO IT MYSELF.
OTHER THAN HAVE TO BARTER WITH
SOMEONE TO GET ME MY WOOD,
I WANNA BE MORE
SELF-SUFFICIENT
BUT IT'S VERY DANGEROUS
FELLING TREES.
I GOT TO LEARN HOW TO
READ THE TREES AND
WHICH WAY THEY'RE
GONNA FALL.
SO, I'VE NATURALLY
PICKED CURLY,
HE IS THE MAN WHEN IT COMES
TO FELLING TREES AND STUFF.
NARRATOR: KNOWN AS
"THE WOODSMAN,"
18-YEAR RESIDENT AND THIRD
GENERATION LOGGER,
TIMOTHY "CURLY" LEACH,
HAS BEEN BEHIND THE
SAW FOR 30-YEARS.
CURLY: MARY, SHE AIN'T AFRAID
TO GET HER HANDS DIRTY.
I MEAN, SHE AIN'T
SCARED OF BEARS,
SHE AIN'T SCARED OF WOLVES,
SHE AIN'T SCARED OF THE
SASQUATCH FOR CRYING
OUT LOUD.
MARY MILLER: WOAH,
YOU SCARED ME!
CURLY: HA-HA, HEY, MARY!
MARY MILLER: HI.
CURLY: SORRY, DIDN'T
MEAN TO SCARE YA.
THAT'S NOT TRUE THOUGH.
YEAH, LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE
YELLOW-CEDAR PILE
IS GETTING DOWN THERE.
MARY MILLER: IT IS, I'VE BEEN
BURNING FAST AS I CAN CHIP IT.
CURLY: YEAH, RIGHT, RIGHT.
RIGHT NOW, PEOPLE ARE
COLLECTING THEIR
FIREWOOD AND THAT, THEY'RE
PRETTY HOT AND HEAVY,
SO I'M GONNA TAKE MARY WITH
ME AND GIVE HER SOME
POINTERS AND STEER HER IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
THAT'S A CUTE LITTLE SAW.
MARY MILLER: WELL, IT'S
A STEP UP FROM THE
BARBIE SAW I WAS USING.
CURLY: YOU DON'T NEED ANYTHING
BIGGER THAN THAT ANYWAY.
MARY MILLER: I'VE JUST
CUT THESE ROUNDS ON
THE BEACH WITH IT IS
ALL I'VE DONE.
CURLY: UH-HUH.
MARY MILLER: I'M
A LITTLE LEERY.
YOU KNOW, YOU READ THE BOX
AND IT SAYS ALL THE DOS
AND DON'TS AND THE CHAIN
KICKING BACK AT YA
AND THE BAR AND STUFF,
VERY FRIGHTENING.
MAYBE I WATCHED TOO MANY
SCARY B MOVIES
WITH CHAINSAWS WHEN
I WANT TO.
CURLY: LOAD UP.
NARRATOR: IN FACT, MARY'S
ANXIETIES ARE WELL-FOUNDED.
AS PROFESSIONS GO, NONE
IS DEADLIER THAN LOGGING.
MARY MILLER: THERE'S SNOW IN
THE FORECAST IN THE NEXT
COUPLE DAYS, SO THIS IS MY
CHANCE TO GET OUT THERE.
I NEED TO GO OUT THERE AND
LEARN THESE SKILLS AND
GET IT RIGHT AND DO IT
NOW, OTHERWISE,
IT'S GONNA BE A LONG
COLD WINTER.
[CHOPPING]
HANS PORTER: NATURE'S THE
MOST POWERFUL FORCE
OUT HERE WE HAVE.
AND IF WE DON'T
MAINTAIN OUR TRAILS,
MOTHER NATURE WILL
OVERTAKE IT AND
YOU'LL NEVER FIND IT AGAIN.
TIMBI PORTER: I HATE
THIS ONE RIGHT HERE,
THIS'LL BE SO NICE
TO GET THIS FIXED.
NARRATOR: HIGH ON THE HILL
BEHIND THEIR PROPERTY,
11-YEAR RESIDENTS,
HANS AND TIMBI PORTER,
ARE FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO
HAVE A MASSIVE SUPPLY
OF FIREWOOD THEY CALL
"THE BLOWDOWN".
HANS PORTER: THERE WE GO.
NARRATOR: BUT KEEPING
THIS RESERVE ACCESSIBLE
ALL YEAR ROUND WILL
REQUIRE A SUBSTANTIAL
OVERHAUL TO THEIR TRAIL.
HANS PORTER: AND EVERY
TIME WE GO UP THERE,
OUR TRAIL JUST KEEPS GETTING
WORSE AND WORSE.
SO, WE'RE GONNA TRY AND
FIX THAT TODAY.
TIMBI PORTER: THIS IS
RIDICULOUS, OH MY GOSH, HANS.
HANS PORTER: YOU MADE IT.
TIMBI PORTER: THE
THINGS I DO FOR YOU!
HANS PORTER: THANK YOU, BABY.
TIMBI PORTER: BEING ABLE TO
GET UP TO THE BLOWDOWN IS,
LIKE, SUPREMELY IMPORTANT.
YOUR ACCESS BACK AND FORTH
TO YOUR WOOD SUPPLY
NEEDS TO BE SAFE.
WHEN YOU RUN OUT OF FIREWOOD,
IT'S SERIOUS.
HANS PORTER: WHAT I'M THINKING
IS, WE CAN TAKE THE ENDS
THAT I'VE CUT OFF AND THEN
PUT THEM IN THE MUD HOLE
AND SET PART OF THAT BEAM
RIGHT UP ON TOP OF IT.
USE IT FOR A BRIDGE.
TIMBI PORTER: I THINK THAT'S
PRETTY DAMN SMART.
HANS PORTER: FOR SOME OF US OUT
HERE IN PORT PROTECTION,
WHO'RE GETTING A
LITTLE BIT OLDER,
SEEMS LIKE OUR CHORES ARE
GETTING A LITTLE BIT
MORE AND MORE DIFFICULT.
TIMBI PORTER: IS THERE
A BOTTOM TO THAT?
HANS PORTER: ANY TIME YOU HAVE
TO GO THROUGH SHIN-DEEP
MUCK TO GET TO
THE JOB SITE,
IT JUST KIND OF TAKES
A TOLL ON YA.
MAY SEEM LIKE A TRAIL TO YOU,
BUT, UH, FOR US ITS SURVIVAL.
TIMBI PORTER: HEY, THAT TURNED
OUT PRETTY WELL, LOOKIE, HEY.
HANS PORTER: 260 POUNDS,
SOLID, ALASKAN TESTED,
WIFE APPROVED.
THE STAIRWAY TO THE
MOUNTAINTOP NEXT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
TIMBI PORTER: I DON'T KNOW,
THIS IS GOING TO BE A PROJECT.
NARRATOR: HAVING ONLY PUT A
DENT INTO THEIR BATTLE WITH
MOTHER NATURE, THE PORTERS
HAVE YET TO TACKLE THE
STEEPEST SECTION OF
THEIR FIREWOOD TRAIL:
THE LENGTHY INCLINE
TO THE BLOWDOWN.
HANS PORTER: THIS IS
WHERE IT'S BAD.
TIMBI PORTER: I KNOW,
EVERY STEP, MAN,
YOU NEVER KNOW IF THE GROUND'S
JUST GONNA GIVE WAY ON YOU
AND YOU'RE GONNA SLIP
IN THAT STUFF.
NARRATOR: IN A
TEMPERATE RAINFOREST,
THE FOREST FLOOR IS LARGELY
COMPOSED OF THICK MOSSES
CARPETING CENTURIES OF
DECOMPOSING DEADFALL,
RESULTING IN SOGGY, UNEVEN AND
OFTEN TREACHEROUS TERRAIN.
HANS PORTER: YOU KNOW WHAT,
MAYBE WE CAN GET
SOME STEPS PUT IN HERE.
TIMBI PORTER: IT LOOKS LIKE
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A HELL
OF A RUN OF STEPS
THOUGH, HUH?
HANS PORTER: WELL, IT'S ALL
UPHILL FROM HERE ON OUT.
GARY MUEHLBERGER:
OVER THE YEARS,
I'VE LEARNED THAT YOU GOT TO
TAKE CARE OF YOURSELF.
THE WINTER SEASON ALWAYS MAKES
EVERYTHING HARDER,
NO MATTER WHAT IT IS.
NARRATOR: SINCE PORT
PROTECTION'S BEGINNING,
THE STAPLE RED MEAT HAS
ALWAYS BEEN VENISON.
GARY MUEHLBERGER: I'M A
LITTLE BIT BEHIND
IN MY HUNTING THIS YEAR, AND A
DOE THERE COULD BE CRUCIAL.
I'LL TELL YA, IT'S A LOT
OF WORK TO MAKE
IT THROUGH THE WINTER.
NARRATOR: HAVING HAD NO
SUCCESS AT TWO HUNTS EARLIER
THIS SEASON, 70-YEAR-OLD GARY
MUEHLBERGER IS CHANGING TACK
IN HIS FINAL EFFORT TO BAG A
DEER BEFORE THE SNOW FALLS.
GARY MUEHLBERGER: WELL, IT FROZE
PRETTY HARD LAST NIGHT;
IT LOOKS LIKE WINTER'S HERE.
THE BACKPACK'S FROZEN.
THE WEATHER MIGHT PUT KIND
OF A KIBOSH TO ME HERE,
IT FROZE REALLY
HARD LAST NIGHT,
AND SO I'M GONNA HAVE TO MAYBE
GO IN THE TIMBER THERE,
THE MUSKEGS ARE
GONNA BE FROZEN,
EVERYWHERE I WALK IS
GONNA BE CRUNCHING,
I'M JUST GONNA BE TELLING
THEM THAT I'M COMING.
SO, I HAVE TO GET A DIFFERENT
APPROACH TO THIS,
AND I'M JUST GONNA HAVE TO
LOOK AND PLAY IT BY EAR.
NARRATOR: GARY PUTS 2.5
NAUTICAL MILES BETWEEN
HIMSELF AND CIVILIZATION
IN ORDER TO BETTER HIS
CHANCES OF A SUCCESSFUL
DEER HUNT.
GARY MUEHLBERGER: YOU CAN'T
GO TODAY, TRAPPER, SORRY.
MOST OF THE DEER ARE SHOT OFF
THAT SHOW THEIR FACE ON THE
ROAD SYSTEM THERE, THOSE ARE
THINNED OUT, THEY'RE GONE.
YOU HAVE TO GET WHERE THEY CAN'T
BE SEEN FROM THE ROAD,
YOU HAVE TO HUNT THOSE
PLACES OUT.
GETTING OLDER NOW AND
THOSE MILES ARE A
LITTLE HARDER FOR ME.
I GOT A 4-WHEELER THERE;
SOMETIMES I CALL IT A SCOOTER.
THE UNIQUE THING ABOUT
THE 4-WHEELER IS
THAT I CAN GET UP AND OFF
OF THE ROAD WHERE
I CAN'T GO WITH A TRUCK.
OPENS UP NEW COUNTRY TO ME.
THE 4-WHEELER SOME PLACES CAN
DRIVE RIGHT UP TO THE DEER,
I CAN WINCH IT UP,
THROW IT ON THERE,
AND I DON'T HAVE TO WORK
AS HARD TO GET IT.
WELL, HERE WE GO.
THERE'S A LOT OF COMPETITION
ON THE ROAD,
THERE'S A LOT OF YOUNG
GUYS THERE.
THEY COVER THE GROUND
PRETTY GOOD,
SO I GOT TO GET OFF THE
BEATEN PATH TO SEE
WHERE THERE IS A DEER.
UH-OH, SOMETHING'S
THE MATTER HERE.
I MEAN, IT FEELS LIKE MAYBE THE
BELT'S SLIPPING OR SOMETHING.
GARY MUEHLBERGER: WHEN
YOU'RE GOING TO DO WHAT I
GOT IN MIND HERE, THERE'S A
FEW TOOLS THAT YOU NEED,
BUT IT'S JUST LIKE
A LOT OF STUFF,
THEY DON'T MAKE 'EM LIKE
THEY USED TO AND
YOU CAN'T RELY ON THEM
ALL THE TIME.
UH-OH, SOMETHING'S
THE MATTER HERE,
DOGGONE.
NARRATOR: MILES FROM
PORT PROTECTION,
A MALFUNCTION IN GARY
MUEHLBERGER'S ATV THREATENS
TO END HIS LATE SEASON DEER
HUNT BEFORE IT'S EVEN BEGUN.
GARY MUEHLBERGER: I
CAN FEEL SOMETHING.
IT FEELS LIKE MAYBE THE BELT'S
SLIPPING OR SOMETHING.
THE MOTOR'S TURNS UP AND
DON'T GO NOWHERE.
I'M THINKING THE OIL FROM
THE CRANKCASE IS GOING
INTO THAT OTHER CHAMBER.
SURE ENOUGH, THE
OIL'S DOWN.
SO, SOMEHOW THE ENGINE OIL
IS GOING INTO THE
CHAMBER WHERE THE BELT IS,
AND SO THE BELT IS SLIPPING.
I KNOW FOR A FACT THAT
THIS ISN'T SOMETHING
I'M GOING TO FIX RIGHT HERE
OR ON THE ROAD HERE.
I'M JUST GONNA HAVE TO COME
UP WITH ANOTHER PLAN.
I GUESS I'LL JUST GO BACK
TO OLD SCHOOL.
GET MY RIFLE AND GO PUT 5
OR 10 MILES ON THE OLD FEET.
THAT'S THE WAY I USED TO
DO IT, HIT THE BRUSH.
AMANDA MAKAR: FINDING MY WAY
HERE IN PORT PROTECTION
HAS BEEN A LITTLE BIT
OF A CHALLENGE.
EVERYBODY HERE'S BEEN SO
HELPFUL AND I AM EXTREMELY
THANKFUL, IT'S MADE LIFE QUITE
A BIT EASIER HERE,
BUT I WOULDN'T HAVE
STAYED IF I DIDN'T
HAVE THE DETERMINATION TO.
NARRATOR: WITH THE OWNERS
SOON RETURNING TO HER CABIN,
THREE YEAR RESIDENT,
AMANDA MAKAR,
HAS ONLY THREE DAYS TO
MOVE INTO HER HOUSEBOAT,
THE WHY NOT, AND MAKE IT
HER PERMANENT HOME
IN PORT PROTECTION.
AMANDA MAKAR: I DON'T WANNA
FREEZE MY ASS OFF.
NARRATOR: BUT IN ORDER TO
STAY WARM DURING THE
COLD NIGHTS ON THE WATER,
AMANDA'S BEST BET FOR
SURVIVAL IS AN OLD-FASHIONED
HEAT SOURCE.
AMANDA MAKAR: THE WHY NOT HAS
ONE DIESEL STOVE ON IT,
BUT I GOTTA MAKE ROOM FOR A
WOOD STOVE BECAUSE
MY DIESEL STOVE
ISN'T WORKING.
TRYING TO GET SOME OF THIS
STUFF OUT OF THE WAY.
PROBABLY ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS TO FIGURE
OUT IN THE WINTERTIME;
KEEPING YOURSELF WARM.
WITHOUT HEAT, YOU'LL DIE.
OH, ANOTHER REASON WHY
YOU SHOULD OIL UP
YOUR RUSTY FASTENERS.
I JUST BUSTED THE TIP OF
MY SCREWDRIVER, SUCKY.
I CALLED ON MY FRIEND,
SAM CARLSON,
TO COME OVER AND HELP
ME PLAN OUT AND
INSTALL THE WOOD STOVE.
SAM CARLSON: YEAH, I WOULD
SAY YOU HAVE YOUR WORK
CUT OUT FOR YOU.
AMANDA MAKAR: AND THE SKY IS
BLUE AND THE GRASS IS GREEN.
SAM CARLSON: YEAH.
WHEN I STEPPED ONBOARD
AMANDA'S HOUSEBOAT,
IT KIND OF BROUGHT BACK
SOME MEMORIES,
BECAUSE I SPENT A WINTER IN ONE
WHEN I WAS IN JUNIOR HIGH,
AND I JUST REMEMBERED
HOW COLD IT WAS.
WOW, YEAH, YOU'RE GONNA
NEED SOME HEAT.
AND ONCE YOU HAVE HEAT,
YOU'LL HAVE A TOTALLY
DIFFERENT ATTITUDE CHANGE.
AMANDA MAKAR:
THAT'LL BE NICE.
SAM CARLSON: YOU'RE GONNA
WANT AT LEAST 12 INCHES
FROM YOUR WALL, JUST FOR FIRE
PROTECTION PURPOSES.
AMANDA MAKAR: MY BIGGEST
WORRY WITH THIS PROJECT
IS POSSIBLY BURNING
THE BOAT DOWN.
FIBERGLASS IS HIGHLY
FLAMMABLE AND
I'M GOING TO PUT A FIRE
SOURCE INSIDE THE BOAT.
SAM CARLSON: ONE OF THE INHERENT
DANGERS IN ACTUALLY
HAVING A WOOD STOVE, ANYWHERE,
YOU WOULD DEFINITELY
HAVE TO HAVE ADEQUATE
FIRE PROTECTION.
THE MAIN THING IS SAFETY,
SAFETY FIRST.
BOATS ARE KIND OF LIKE TRAILER
HOUSES, CONFINED SPACES,
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A LITTLE
EXTRA FIRE PROTECTION.
AMANDA MAKAR: I DO HAVE FAITH
IN SAM AND HIS CAPABILITIES.
I ATTEMPTED IT EARLIER
BUT I BROKE MY TIP
TRYING TO GET THIS.
SAM CARLSON: WHOOPS, I THOUGHT
MAYBE I COULD PULL IT OUT.
AMANDA MAKAR: LET'S
NOT DO THAT.
SAM CARLSON: IT FELT LIKE IT
WOULD JUST COME RIGHT OUT,
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT'S
ATTACHED TO.
AMANDA MAKAR: THE WALL.
BUT WHEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE
COMING OVER AND JUST TEARING
PIECES OFF OF YOUR HOME IT CAN
BE RATHER CONCERNING.
SAM CARLSON: THIS IS GONNA GET
COVERED UP WITH DRYWALL SO
YOU'RE NOT GONNA
SEE ANY OF THIS.
JOB DONE.
AMANDA MAKAR: HANDLE REMOVED.
SAM CARLSON: UH-HMM, IT'S
A WEE BIT OF A CHALLENGE.
I'VE NEVER ACTUALLY INSTALLED
A STOVE, A WOOD STOVE,
IN A BOAT.
HOPEFULLY, WE WILL
BE SUCCESSFUL.
CURLY: TREE FELLING'S
A VERY DANGEROUS,
DANGEROUS OCCUPATION.
THAT TREE CAN BITE YOU BACK
IN A HEARTBEAT AND
YOU MIGHT NOT LIVE
TO TELL THE STORY.
ALL RIGHT.
MARY MILLER: THIS
IS THE SPOT?
CURLY: YEAH, THERE IS ONE
RIGHT UP HERE THAT
I HAD PICKED OUT
FOR YA THERE.
MARY MILLER: IT IS A LOT
OF CEDARS UP IN THERE.
NARRATOR: 2.5 NAUTICAL MILES
EAST OF PORT PROTECTION,
SEASONED LOGGER,
TIMOTHY "CURLY" LEACH,
HAS BROUGHT SEVEN YEAR
RESIDENT MARY MILLER OUT ON
THE ROAD TO TEACH HER
HOW TO CHOP DOWN A DEAD,
STANDING TREE.
MARY MILLER: I THINK
I COULD HANDLE IT,
I WILL GIVE IT A SHOT.
I CARRY MY SAW LIKE CURLY
AND LOOK COOL NOW.
BEFORE I MOVED HERE I'VE
NEVER USED A CHAINSAW.
I COULDN'T EVEN LIFT THE MAUL
FOR SPLITTING ROUNDS,
BUT NOW I COULD SWING
IT ALL DAY LONG
AND SPLIT THAT WOOD
UP, YIKES.
CURLY: NICE EASY ONE THOUGH.
MARY MILLER: YEAH, EASY
FOR YOU TO SAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE HELL
YOU'RE DOING.
YOU JUST ACCLIMATE TO
WHAT YOU NEED TO DO
TO SURVIVE OUT HERE.
OH, I DON'T KNOW.
THIS IS SCARY, CURLY,
I CAN'T HELP IT.
CURLY: YEAH, I THINK SHE'S
PRETTY NERVOUS ABOUT IT.
SHE'S A LITTLE GUN-SHY
WITH THEM CHAINSAWS,
WHICH IS A GOOD THING.
MARY MILLER: I'M JUST GOING
TO GO, "AHH, I ALREADY KNOW."
CURLY: THEY SAY IF YOU'RE
NOT SCARED, YOU KNOW,
YOU AIN'T GOT NO BUSINESS
CUTTING TREES.
WHEN OPERATING A CHAINSAW,
YOU GOT TO REMEMBER THAT
SAW IS NOT YOUR FRIEND, IT'S
NOT GOING TO WATCH OUT FOR YA.
YOU'RE GOING TO CUT FLAT
INTO IT LIKE THAT.
MARY MILLER: GOOD LORD.
CURLY: YEAH.
MARY MILLER: OKAY.
NARRATOR: CHOPPING DOWN A
TREE IS DANGEROUS BUSINESS.
AS SHE WORKS, MARY
MUST KEEP AN EYE OUT FOR
FALLING LIMBS,
KICKBACK FROM HER SAW,
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST,
THE TREE ITSELF FALLING
IN HER DIRECTION.
MARY MILLER: BOY, I DON'T KNOW,
CURLY, IF I FEEL SAFE.
HOW AM I GOING TO LEAN OVER
THERE, GOING DOWNHILL,
WITH A CHAINSAW RUNNING?
YEAH, RIGHT!
CURLY: YOU CAN DO IT,
YOU'RE ALL RIGHT.
MARY MILLER: SMELL'S
FLOODED, I SMELL GAS.
CURLY: YOU SMELL GAS?
MARY MILLER: YEAH.
CURLY: RIGHT, HERE.
MARY MILLER: IT NEEDS YOU.
CURLY: THERE.
MARY MILLER: BOY,
I DON'T LIKE IT.
CURLY: I'LL COACH YOU THROUGH
IT THOUGH, GO AHEAD.
PUT DOWN YOUR HANDLEBARS
NOW, GET DOWN AND
JUST LET THE SAW GO.
IT'S KIND OF DIFFERENT
WATCHING SOMEBODY
ELSE CUTTING A TREE.
USUALLY, I'M ON
THE END OF THE SAW.
YOU WANT THAT POINTED,
RIGHT TO THE LEFT
OF THEM ALDERS, OKAY?
YOU'RE ALL RIGHT, YOU'RE DOING
JUST FINE, DON'T FREAK!
MARY MILLER: ALL I COULD
THINK OF IS THAT TREE IS
COMING DOWN ON ME, I'M GONNA
ROLL DOWN THE HILL, YOU KNOW?
ALL THESE THINGS THAT
COULD HAPPEN.
CURLY: THERE YOU GO,
TRY THAT, THERE YA GO!
MARY MILLER: AH, HOLY (BLEEP)
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THIS STUFF!
CURLY: MARY, YOU GOT TO
HAVE YOUR SAW FLAT.
MARY MILLER:
AS OF RIGHT NOW,
I AM SCARED TO
DEATH OF THE THING.
CURLY: STOP.
MARY MILLER: OH, GOD,
CURLY.
CURLY: YOUR FINE, YOU'RE
DOING JUST FINE.
LET ME GET BACK OVER HERE
AND I'M GONNA WATCH.
MARY MILLER: CURLY, IT
WANTS TO GO THE OTHER WAY,
IT'S STARTING TO MOVE!
CURLY: YOU'RE FINE, DON'T PANIC,
JUST GO AHEAD AND CUT!
KEEP GOING,
MARY, DON'T STOP!
CUT FAST, CUT FAST,
KEEP GOING,
DON'T STOP, COME ON!
MARY MILLER: CURLY, IT WANTS
TO GO THE OTHER WAY,
IT'S STARTING TO MOVE!
CURLY: DON'T PANIC, JUST
GO AHEAD AND CUT.
NARRATOR: OUT IN THE
ALASKAN WILDERNESS,
FIRST- TIME LOGGER,
MARY MILLER,
CONFRONTS HER FIRST
DEAD-STANDING TREE.
AN INTIMIDATING
90-FOOT YELLOW CEDAR.
CURLY: KEEP GOING,
MARY, DON'T STOP...
CUT FAST, CUT FAST,
KEEP GOING.
CUT FAST, DON'T STOP,
COME ON...
GET OVER HERE.
SEE, YOU DID IT!
MARY MILLER: OH,
MAN, I DID IT, YAY!
CURLY: YOU DID IT, GOT AN
ADRENALINE RUSH GOING?
MARY MILLER: GOD, MY
HEART IS POUNDING.
CURLY: I BET.
MARY MILLER: WHEN THE
TREE FINALLY CAME DOWN,
IT WAS SO MANY DIFFERENT
EMOTIONS GOING
THROUGH MY HEAD.
I MEAN, IT'S LIKE, RELIEF
IT'S DOWN, YOU KNOW.
YOU'RE TELLING ME TO CUT
FAST AND THE DROPS WERE
COMING DOWN FROM THE
TREE AND HITTING ME.
IT'S LIKE, "OH, THE SON OF
A BITCH IS MOVING."
CURLY: YOU FROZE IN
YOUR TRACKS.
THE EXPRESSION ON HER FACE
WAS PRETTY PRICELESS.
YOU KNOW, FIRST TIME EVEN
REALLY RUNNING A SAW PERIOD,
YOU KNOW, AND TO JUMP IN
TO CUTTING A TREE,
SHE DID A GOOD JOB, YOU KNOW,
I WAS PRETTY PROUD OF HER.
MARY MILLER: GOOD LORD,
THAT'S MORE OF A RUSH
THAN DROPPING A DEER,
LET ME TELL YA.
EVERYTHING WORKED OUT OKAY.
EVERYONE WAS SAFE, BUT NOW
THE HARD PART STARTS WHERE
I GOT TO SAW 'EM UP AND
SPLIT 'EM AND GET IT STACKED.
TIMBI PORTER: WHAT MAKES A
PLACE LIKE PORT PROTECTION
REALLY WORK IS THAT WE END UP
HELPING EACH OTHER MORE
THAN WE'RE REALLY AWARE
OF BECAUSE IT KIND OF
BECOMES SECOND NATURE.
NARRATOR: IN ORDER TO REACH
THEIR FIREWOOD SUPPLY,
HANS AND TIMBI PORTER ARE
FORCED TIME AND AGAIN
TO CLIMB A MUDDY,
SLIPPERY TRAIL TO
THE TOP OF A MOUNTAIN.
TIMBI PORTER: I THINK THESE
STEPS ARE GOING TO
BECOME KIND OF INVOLVED,
DON'T YOU?
HANS PORTER: WELL, I'VE ALWAYS
FOUND THAT STEPS
ARE ALWAYS AN UPHILL BATTLE.
NARRATOR: MAKING THE SOGGY
RAINFOREST FLOOR ACCESSIBLE
SOMETIMES REQUIRES
EXPERIENCE AND TOOLS BORNE
OF DECADES SURVIVING
THE ALASKAN BUSH.
TIMBI PORTER:
HEY, YOU MADE IT!
BUD BAKER: MADE IT,
BETTER LATE THAN NEVER.
HANS PORTER: LIVING OUT HERE,
WE TRY TO USE ALL THE
RESOURCES THAT WE CAN
AT OUR DISPOSAL,
AND ONE OF THE GREATEST
RESOURCES I KNOW IS BUD.
TIMBI PORTER: LOOK
WHAT YOU BROUGHT!
BUD BAKER: NOW WE JUST
GOT TO DO STAIRS.
HANS PORTER: I'VE BEEN
HELPING BUD GET WOOD FOR
THE LAST COUPLE YEAR SO
I INVITED HIM TO COME UP
AND HELP US SO WE CAN
KEEP THE WOOD FLOWING.
BUD BAKER: STRAIGHT
UP AND DOWN ALMOST!
TIMBI PORTER: SLIPPERY!
BUD BAKER: YEAH.
HANS PORTER:
STRAIGHT UP AND DOWN.
TIMBI PORTER: GOSH,
I CAN'T EVEN STAY UP.
WHY DON'T WE JUST PUT
IN AN ESCALATOR?
BUD BAKER: YEAH, RIGHT.
OH, WE GOT LOTS OF
STUFF TO WORK WITH.
TIMBI PORTER: I THINK THAT
THERE IS SO MUCH VALUABLE
INFORMATION THAT THE
PEOPLE IN THIS VILLAGE HAVE,
FINDING OUT THE LITTLE
TRICKS AND TIPS FROM
PEOPLE LIKE BUD,
IT'S HUGE TO US.
THIS IS YOUR FROE?
BUD BAKER: YEAH.
TIMBI PORTER: AND
DID YOU MAKE THAT?
BUD BAKER: YES.
TIMBI PORTER: THAT'S
PRETTY AWESOME.
BUD BAKER: HEMLOCK BRANCH
AND A RUBBER TIRE.
RUBBER COMPRESSES AND IT
FIRES IT DOWN INTO THE WOOD.
TIMBI PORTER: BUD'S BROUGHT
UP A SHAKE FROE AND
A MALLET AND THESE ARE
SOME OLD TIMEY TOOLS.
HANS PORTER: AND WE'LL DO IT
THE OLD FASHIONED WAY.
NARRATOR: BUD'S LIGHTWEIGHT
TOOLS, HOWEVER UNASSUMING,
HAVE BEEN ESSENTIAL TO
CENTURIES OF CONSTRUCTION.
HANS PORTER: OKAY, READY?
BUD BAKER: YEAH.
NARRATOR: THE TEAM MAKES
THE STEPS BY PLACING THE FROE'S
BLADE AGAINST THE LOG AND
HITTING IT WITH THE MALLET,
CREATING PRECISELY
MEASURED SHAKE BOARDS
WITHOUT THE CUMBERSOME
AID OF A MODERN MILL.
TIMBI PORTER: OH, NO!
BUD BAKER:
THAT'S WHY, THAT'S.
HANS PORTER: WELL,
WE HAVE A PROBLEM.
BUD BAKER: I GUESS WE'RE
DONE FOR TODAY.
HANS PORTER: THE THING
ABOUT MAKING BOARDS,
THE MALLET THAT YOU
USE IS GONNA BREAK,
IT'S JUST A MATTER
OF WHEN.
I AIN'T GOT NOTHING
TO SWAT IT WITH, BRO.
I'M SORRY ABOUT
BREAKING YOUR MALLET,
BUT I CAN BUILD
YOU A NEW ONE.
BUD BAKER: WE CAN, WELL,
LET'S GO DO IT.
HANS PORTER: ALL RIGHT.
BUD BAKER: IT'S GOOD.
TIMBI PORTER: AT A STANDSTILL
UNTIL WE GET A NEW ONE, OKAY.
HANS PORTER: OUT HERE, IT'S
THE LITTLE THINGS THAT
THROW YOU OFF, BUT IT'S
ALWAYS SOMETHING.
GARY MUEHLBERGER: THE BEST-LAID
PLANS OF MICE AND MEN,
THEY CAN CHANGE.
BUT YOU CAN'T DWELL ON THAT,
YOU GOT TO ROLL WITH IT AND
JUST SAY TO YOURSELF,
"WELL, YOU'RE JUST GONNA
HAVE TO DO IT THE HARD WAY."
NARRATOR: AFTER RUNNING INTO A
BELT ISSUE WITH HIS ATV,
70-YEAR-OLD GARY MUEHLBERGER
PUSHES DEEP INTO THE
ALASKAN BUSH TO CONTINUE
HIS DOE HUNT
THE OLD-FASHIONED WAY,
ALONE AND ON FOOT.
GARY MUEHLBERGER: WELL,
YOU CAN SEE THERE'S BEEN
DEER ALL OVER HERE,
THERE'S TRACKS ALL OVER.
EVEN AT MY AGE, I RELY ON MY
LEGS AND HIPS AND MY BODY TO
TAKE ME WHERE I WANNA GO AND
SO, THAT'S HOW I'M GONNA HUNT.
ONE OF THE THINGS ABOUT
HUNTING ON FOOT,
YOU CAN GO PLACES
WHERE EVEN THE ATV CAN'T GO.
THERE'S ANOTHER DEER
BED RIGHT HERE.
WELL, THERE'S DEER
(BLEEP) RIGHT THERE.
THEY'RE LIVING HERE.
WITH A LITTLE LUCK, I
CAN SNEAK UP ON ONE.
HE RUBBED THE (BLEEP)
OUT OF THIS RIGHT HERE.
THERE'S A DEER.
DO YOU SEE IT?
IT'S A DOE.
GARY MUEHLBERGER: THERE'S DEER
ALL OVER THIS COUNTRY HERE.
WELL, HE RUBBED THE (BLEEP)
OUT OF THIS RIGHT HERE.
NARRATOR: FOUR MILES
INTO HIS TREK,
HUNTER GARY MUEHLBERGER HAS
FOUND HIMSELF ON A CLOSED
LOGGING ROAD, ABUNDANT
WITH DEER SIGN.
GARY MUEHLBERGER:
THERE'S A DEER.
DO YOU SEE IT?
IT'S A DOE, THERE
SHE GOES.
YEAH, WELL, IT WAS STANDING
RIGHT THERE, I HAD A,
YOU KNOW, DEAD SHOT,
BUT YOU CAN SEE
YOU CAN'T GET HERE WITH
A FOUR-WHEELER.
IT'S HELL FOR ME, PACK
ONE OUT OF HERE.
BUT ANYWAY, THAT'S, GIVE
ME A LITTLE CHARGE,
WE'LL GO UP THIS WAY.
THERE WAS ONE HERE,
I'D SAY THERE'S MORE.
BUD BAKER: TRY THIS
ONE MORE TIME.
HANS PORTER: IT'S PRETTY
HARD LIVING OUT HERE.
BUD BAKER: BACK
IN BUSINESS!
TIMBI PORTER: NICE YOU GUYS!
HANS PORTER: I'VE FOUND
THAT IT'S A LOT EASIER
TO GET THINGS ACCOMPLISHED
WHEN YOU WORK TOGETHER.
NARRATOR: WITH THE
NEW MALLET ASSEMBLED,
THE PORTERS AND NEIGHBOR
BUD BAKER FINISH CONSTRUCTING
SHAKE BOARDS AND STAKES USING
OLD-FASHIONED TOOLS
AND THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AROUND THEM.
BUD BAKER: 6, 7, 8
OF THEM NOW.
NARRATOR: ALL THAT'S LEFT IS
TO CONSTRUCT THE STAIRS
AND PRAY THEY'LL HOLD.
TIMBI PORTER: WOW, THOSE ARE
HEAVY, IT MUST BE HEMLOCK.
BUD BAKER: HEMLOCK, YEAH.
HANS PORTER: THAT
AIN'T GOING NOWHERE,
IT'LL BE THERE FOR A WHILE.
TIMBI PORTER: FOR BUD TO
STOP UP AND HELP US,
IT'S THIS NEIGHBOR HELPING
NEIGHBOR HELPING NEIGHBOR
THAT MAKES THIS
COMMUNITY WORK.
IT SEEMS LIKE A LOT OF
PEOPLE PAY IT FORWARD.
HANS PORTER: THOSE ARE
SOME NICE LOOKING BOARDS, GIRL!
TIMBI PORTER: THEY ARE
NICE LOOKING BOARDS!
IT'S COME ALONG SO WELL.
WE'RE WORKING TOGETHER TO
ACHIEVE SOMETHING
THAT'S GONNA BENEFIT US AND
WE TRY TO DO IT WITH
LOVE AND COMPASSION
FOR EACH OTHER.
HANS PORTER: THAT'S REALLY
WHAT IT'S ALL ABOUT FOR US.
YOU GET A PROJECT, GO TO WORK,
HAVE A GOOD TIME,
GET HER DONE,
CALL IT A DAY.
JUST ABOUT RIGHT?
BUD BAKER: YEAH.
HANS PORTER: ANOTHER ONE
JUST ABOUT RIGHT, BUD?
BUD BAKER: JUST ABOUT.
TIMBI PORTER: OH, TWO
IN A ROW, HANS!
HANS PORTER: BOY, THESE
ARE SOME NICE STEPS!
TIMBI PORTER: LOOK AT THIS,
YOU GUYS, THIS IS HUGE.
BUD BAKER: WE WON'T BE MUD
UP TO OUR NECK.
TIMBI PORTER: YEAH.
HANS PORTER: OR ANYTHING ELSE.
TIMBI PORTER: OR ANYTHING
ELSE, THIS IS SO COOL.
BUD BAKER: HEY, THERE'S
HOLES OUT THERE
YOU CAN LOSE A
SMALL KID IN.
SAM CARLSON: IF YOU REALLY
WANT A TASTE OF PERSONAL
FREEDOM AND JUST ALL AROUND
SELF-SUFFICIENCY,
NOTHING QUITE LIKE OWNING
YOUR OWN HOME.
AT THIS STAGE OF THE GAME,
FOR AMANDA, IN HER LIFE,
IT'S DEFINITELY GONNA BE A
STRUGGLE TO, YOU KNOW,
GET THINGS WHIPPED
INTO SHAPE.
BUT THAT BUILDS CHARACTER.
NARRATOR: WITH DAYS REMAINING
BEFORE HER MOVE,
AMANDA MAKAR AND HER FRIEND
SAM CARLSON ARE
SCRAMBLING TO BUILD A WOOD
BURNING STOVE TO HELP
HEAT THE 33-YEAR-OLD'S
NEW HOUSEBOAT DURING
THE WINTER CHILL.
AMANDA MAKAR: THE WHY NOT
IS MY VERY FIRST RESIDENCE,
SO IT'S PRETTY IMPORTANT TO
ME TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
OF THESE PROJECTS
ARE DONE PROPERLY.
NARRATOR: WHILE AMANDA
FIREPROOFS THE WALLS OF
HER HOUSEBOAT, SAM
CONSTRUCTS THE WOODSTOVE
OUT OF SALVAGED MATERIALS.
SAM CARLSON: AMANDA, SHE
KNOWS THAT I HAVE SKILLS
WITH MAKING THINGS FROM
SCRAP AND IT'S ALWAYS GOOD
TO BE ABLE TO SHARE
THAT KNOWLEDGE.
I LIVED ON MY BOAT WHEN
I WAS 16 AND A HALF.
I HAD LOTS OF HELP.
THERE'S NO WAY IN HELL
I COULD CLAIM THAT
I DIDN'T HAVE LOTS OF HELP.
BUT THERE WERE ENOUGH
OLD TIMERS AROUND,
CRUSTY OLD FARTS THAT
WERE MORE THAN WILLING
TO JUST TELL YOU,
"THIS IS HOW YOU DO IT."
AMANDA MAKAR: TIME TO
CUT SOME SHEET ROCK,
TWENTY-FIVE AND
THREE QUARTERS.
I FEEL PRETTY INTIMIDATED
BY MY WOOD STOVE.
I DON'T WANNA CATCH
ANYTHING ON FIRE,
BURN SOMEBODY ELSE'S
HOUSE DOWN,
OR PUT ANYBODY ELSE'S
LIVES IN JEOPARDY.
WHAT THIS DOES IS IT CREATES
A GAP BETWEEN THE WALL
AND THE SHEET ROCK
SO THAT THINGS HAVE A
CHANCE TO KEEP COOL, TA-DA!
SO NOTHING CATCHES ON FIRE.
SAM CARLSON: I'D SAY IT'S
ABOUT FACTORY PERFECT.
ALWAYS NICE WHEN A PLAN
COMES TOGETHER.
TAKE THIS OVER TO AMANDA'S
AND HOPEFULLY,
SHE'LL HAVE A HOT BOAT
BY TOMORROW.
AHOY, SPECIAL DELIVERY.
AND THERE YOU GO.
AMANDA MAKAR: GOT IT.
SAM CARLSON: GOT IT.
AMANDA MAKAR:
LOOKS GREAT, SAM!
SAM CARLSON: ALL RIGHT,
YEAH, THAT LOOKS GREAT.
AMANDA MAKAR: I HIRED THE
RIGHT MAN FOR THE JOB.
SAM CARLSON: AND THIS,
THEY'LL BE,
AND I'D LIKE TO SEE THAT AT
LEAST THAT FAR FROM THIS WALL.
AMANDA MAKAR: UH-HUH.
SAM CARLSON: OH (BLEEP)
SEE, WE'RE OFF.
SAM CARLSON: SPECIAL DELIVERY,
AND THERE YOU GO.
AMANDA MAKAR: GOT IT.
SAM CARLSON: GOT IT.
AMANDA MAKAR:
LOOKS GREAT, SAM!
NARRATOR: WITH THE NEW
WOOD STOVE ASSEMBLED,
SAM RETURNS TO AMANDA'S
HOUSEBOAT TO
COMPLETE THE INSTALLATION.
SAM CARLSON: I'D LIKE TO
SEE THAT AT LEAST
THAT FAR FROM THIS WALL.
AMANDA MAKAR: UH-HUH.
NARRATOR: BUT HE DISCOVERS A
GLARING ISSUE.
SAM CARLSON: OH (BLEEP)
SEE, WE'RE OFF.
WE CAN'T USE THIS
AS THE MIDDLE.
STOVEPIPE'S ACTUALLY
GONNA BE OVER HERE.
NARRATOR: HAVING FAILED
TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THE PLACEMENT OF THE
CEILING JOIST,
SAM AND AMANDA WILL NOW
HAVE TO SHIFT THE
STOVES INSTALLATION ONE
FOOT TO THE RIGHT.
SAM CARLSON: I DON'T GENERALLY
DRAW UP PLANS OR SCHEMATICS.
I JUST HAVE THIS THING
IN MY HEAD.
GENERALLY, THERE'S ALWAYS
MODIFICATIONS ON THE
FLY WHILE YOU'RE
DOING THE JOB,
SO I JUST HOPE THERE'S NO
BIG STUMBLING BLOCK.
AMANDA MAKAR: GOD,
I HOPE THIS WORKS,
I CAN'T BELIEVE WE'RE
CUTTING A HOLE IN
MY PERFECTLY FINE ROOF.
SAM CARLSON: I HEAR AMANDA
DOWN BELOW GOING
"I CANNOT BELIEVE
SOMEBODY IS CUTTING A HOLE
IN THE ROOF OF THE BOAT."
YOU GO AHEAD
AND PUSH ON IT!
THERE YOU GO.
AMANDA MAKAR: SORRY!
SAM CARLSON: THAT'S IT,
DIDN'T GET ME.
THERE'S BEEN A
TREND IN ALASKA,
PEOPLE MOVING OUT OF THE
BUSH AND THEN, YOU KNOW,
BACK INTO THE CITIES
AND IT'S NICE TO SEE YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT ARE
HANGING IN THERE, TOUGH,
LEARNING HOW TO DO
EVERYTHING RIGHT.
I THINK THAT YOU'RE GOOD.
AMANDA MAKAR: OKAY.
SAM CARLSON: YEAH, I THINK
YOU'RE GOOD, THAT'S FINE.
AMANDA MAKAR: I CAME TO PORT
PROTECTION BECAUSE OF A BOY.
THAT RELATIONSHIP DID NOT WORK
OUT AND I DECIDED TO STAY.
THIS PLACE HAS
CAPTIVATED ME SO.
THERE'S SO MANY THINGS
THAT KEEP ME HERE.
THE ENERGY, THE PEOPLE,
THE LIFESTYLE,
AND I CAN'T SEE WANTING TO
LEAVE IT ANY TIME SOON.
SAM CARLSON: I THINK IT'S TIME
TO CHRISTEN THE STOVEPIPE.
GARY MUEHLBERGER: I'VE
HUNTED DEER FOR TWO WEEKS
AT A TIME WITHOUT
GETTING ONE.
[MAKING DEER CALL]
COMING HOME EMPTY HANDED.
NARRATOR: HUNTER GARY
MUEHLBERGER HAS HIKED FOUR
MILES INTO THE ALASKAN BUSH,
DOWN CLOSED-OFF LOGGING ROADS,
IN HOPES OF FINALLY BAGGING A
DEER FOR HIS WINTER STORE.
GARY MUEHLBERGER: ALL YOU GOT
TO DO IS JUST MAKE A LITTLE
BIT OF NOISE AND THEM DEER
WILL EVADE YOU,
THEY CIRCLE AROUND BEHIND
YOU AND YOU NEVER
SEE THEM AGAIN, SO, WINTER
ISN'T WHAT GETS YOU,
IT'S NOT BEING PREPARED FOR
WINTER THAT'S WHAT'LL GET YOU.
I NEED A CERTAIN AMOUNT, IF I
DON'T CATCH ONE TODAY,
THIS IS MY LAST CHANCE
FOR THIS YEAR.
I JUST KIND OF HAVE A LITTLE
FEELING FOR WHERE I AM
AND DIFFERENT DIRECTION.
I'M SWITCHING DIRECTIONS
ALL THE TIME,
BUT I'M JUST GOING BY
THE DEER TRAIL.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY MORE
YEARS I'LL BE ABLE TO THIS,
BUT I CAN GIVE THE YOUNG
GUYS A LITTLE RUN FOR
THEIR MONEY JUST BECAUSE
OF EXPERIENCE.
THEY MAKE IT TOUGH,
DON'T THEY?
BUT THERE'S DEER ALL OVER
IN THIS COUNTRY HERE.
THIS IS FRESH, IT
AIN'T FROZEN.
WELL, THERE'S DEER HERE.
THERE'S ALL KIND
OF SIGN THERE,
THEY'RE RUBBING ALL
OVER HERE.
THIS IS GOOD A SPOT AS ANY,
MAYBE BETTER THAN SOME.
YOU JUST HAVE TO
KEEP TRYING.
EVENTUALLY, ONE WILL
MAKE A MISTAKE
AND HOPEFULLY, I WON'T.
THEY'RE LIVING HERE,
SO, SOMETHING'S AHEAD
OF US RIGHT HERE.
IT'S PRETTY BRUSHY, BUT
THERE'S STILL A FEW OPEN SPOTS.
DID YOU SEE IT?
[GUNSHOT]
SHE'S RUNNING.
GARY MUEHLBERGER:
IT'S PRETTY BRUSHY,
BUT THERE'S STILL A
FEW OPEN SPOTS.
DID YOU SEE IT?
NARRATOR: AFTER THREE
HOURS TRAVELING ON FOOT,
SEVENTY-YEAR-OLD GARY
MEUHLBERGER FINALLY
HAS A DEER IN HIS SIGHTS.
[GUNSHOT]
GARY MUEHLBERGER:
SHE'S RUNNING.
I'M GONNA PUT
HER DOWN THERE.
[GUNSHOT]
SHE'S DEAD,
IT'S A BIG DOE.
WASN'T A GOOD SHOT,
WENT DOWN.
THIS IS WHAT I WANTED,
THIS IS MY CHRISTMAS PRESENT
RIGHT HERE, SO THANK
YOU LORD, FOR THIS DEER.
THE OLD WAY IS THE
GOOD WAY FOR ME.
I'M IN PRETTY GOOD PHYSICAL
CONDITION BECAUSE
I WALK A LOT AND
WHAT I EAT.
I WAS REALLY SURPRISED
I COULD STILL RUN.
YOU WANNA DISPATCH THIS DEER
AS QUICK AS POSSIBLE.
THE BLOOD'S THE FIRST
THING TO SPOIL.
AND ONCE YOU GET THE
BACTERIA GOING,
THEN YOU DON'T
HAVE TOO LONG.
IF YOU CAN GET THEM
BLED OUT, GOOD.
YOU'LL HAVE SOME MEAT
THAT'LL LAST LONGER.
I GOT TO GET MOVING HERE.
IT'S GETTING DARKER AND I
GOT A WAYS TO WALK HERE
BEFORE I BE BACK TO
TRANSPORTATION.
WHEN YOU GET OUT IN
THE WOODS THERE,
OFF THE ROAD WAY OUT THERE,
YOU GOT TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT YOU'RE GONNA DO
ONCE YOU GET A DEER.
YEAH, BOY, I WISH I HAD THAT
FOUR-WHEELER RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
I COULD JUST PUT IT ON THE BACK
AND IT'D BE ALL DONE.
BUT IT'S BROKE DOWN AS IT IS,
I GOT TO MAKE A PACK OUT OF
THIS THING AND BE
THE MULE HERE.
GOOD THING MY NAME
IS MUEHLBERGER.
IN THE OLD DAYS, MY BROTHER
TAUGHT ME HOW TO MAKE A
BACKPACK OUT OF THIS DEER BY
TOGGLING THE FRONT LEGS.
I GOT THESE LEGS SKINNED OUT TO
MAKE A TOGGLE OUT OF THEM.
SO YOU TAKE IT LIKE THIS AND
YOU PUT YOUR FOOT THROUGH
THERE, PULL IT ON THROUGH, AND
THEN THERE'S YOUR TOGGLE.
THAT HOLDS THAT ONE.
YOU TAKE THE OTHER ONE,
SHOVE THE FOOT THROUGH,
TOGGLE IT OVER.
WELL, NOW YOU KNOW WHY I
WEAR A RED COAT BECAUSE
THIS ONE'S GOING TO TURN
RED PRETTY QUICK.
IT'S NOT THE EASIEST
THING TO DO.
BUT SINCE I DIDN'T HAVE MY
FOUR-WHEELER OR MY TRUCK,
THAT'S WHAT I'M GONNA DO
IS PACK IT ON MY BACK
THE OLD SCHOOL WAY.
I KIND OF PROVED SOMETHING TO
MYSELF TODAY.
I HAVEN'T DONE THIS
FOR A LONG TIME.
I COULD SHOOT A DEER,
PUT IT ON MY BACK,
GO THROUGH THE WOODS,
BRING IT BACK HOME.
I'M 70 YEARS OLD AND I STILL
COULD PUT THAT DEER
ON MY BACK AND PACK IT.
I LOOK IN THE MIRROR AND
THERE'S THIS OLD GUY THERE,
BUT I DON'T SEE ME THERE,
I'M STILL A YOUNG GUY.
MARY MILLER: THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS THAT WE DO OUT HERE
TO SURVIVE AND MAKE OUR LIVES
MORE COMFORTABLE.
A LOT OF IT'S VERY DANGEROUS
AND YOU GET YOURSELF
IN SOME PRETTY SCARY
PREDICAMENT,
BUT YOU GOT TO LEARN BECAUSE
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY
YOU'RE GONNA NOT BE RELYING
ON OTHER PEOPLE.
NARRATOR: ON THE ROAD, CURLY
AND MARY RETURN TO THE TREE
THEY FELL THE DAY BEFORE.
MARY MILLER: WHY'S IT GOT
TO BE SO COLD?
IT MAKES EVERYTHING
TWICE AS EXHAUSTING.
YEAH, THE FORECAST CALLS FOR
THE SNOW TO BE FALLING
PRETTY HEAVY HERE COMING UP
THIS WHOLE NEXT WEEK,
SO IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
TO GET SOME GOOD
HOT BURNING WOOD.
ME TOES IS FROZE.
CURLY: OKAY, YOU WANNA
FLIP THAT OVER MARY.
THERE YOU GO, YOU
GOT IT NOW.
MARY MILLER: SORRY, CURLY,
HAVING YOU HAVING TO BABYSIT.
CURLY: WELL, THAT'S ALL RIGHT,
YOU'LL, YOU GOT TO LEARN.
WHEN TEACHING MARY
HOW TO DO THIS,
I KIND OF FEEL A LITTLE BIT
RESPONSIBLE, YOU KNOW,
TAKING HER UNDER MY WING
AND THAT, YOU KNOW,
JUST PICK UP SOME GENERAL
POINTERS THAT
ARE GONNA KEEP HER
SAFE OUT THERE.
WELL, HERE WE GO.
MARY MILLER: OKAY,
LET'S DO IT.
GOD, YOU JUST MAKE IT
LOOK SO EASY, CURLY.
SOMEDAY, I WILL
BE THAT GOOD.
I'M FAIRLY LUCKY TO HAVE
A FRIEND LIKE CURLY.
IT'S JUST HUGE THAT PEOPLE
THAT HAVE BEEN HERE,
HOW MUCH THEY CAN HELP YOU
IN YOUR DAY-TO-DAY LIFE.
MAN, THIS THING WEIGHS
A TON, BEAUTIFUL.
CURLY: THE NUMBER ONE THING IS
IT'LL PROBABLY GIVE HER MORE
CONFIDENCE IN HERSELF
ABOUT GOING OUT AND
ACTUALLY DOING IT
ON HER OWN.
KEEP COMING, PERFECT!
MARY MILLER: OKAY, NOW,
DO I GO THIS WAY OR?
CURLY: GET IT IN
THE CUT FIRST.
MARY MILLER: BEFORE
YOU GAS IT UP.
CURLY: RIGHT.
MARY MILLER: THROTTLE UP.
CURLY: YEAH.
MARY MILLER: I'LL ALWAYS
BE AFRAID OF THE
SAW AND RESPECT IT.
A VERY DANGEROUS TOOL AND YOU
MUST HAVE A LOT OF RESPECT
FOR IT AND KNOW HOW TO
USE IT OR DON'T
BE MESSING AROUND WITH IT.
I'M GLAD THAT CURLY TOOK THE
TIME OUT TO TAKE ME OUT TO DO
THAT BECAUSE I FEEL A LOT MORE
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT SAW NOW.
BY THE END OF THE DAY,
I WAS, YOU KNOW,
I HAD A LOT MORE CONFIDENCE AND
IT'S JUST ONE MORE STEP IN
BEING ABLE TO CONQUER
ALL THESE FEARS AND
DO THESE THINGS MYSELF.
CURLY: I CAN SEE MARY GOING
OUT AND I CAN SEE HER REALLY
GETTING INTO THIS TREE FALLING
STUFF, YOU KNOW, I'M,
I THINK SHE'LL BE REALLY GOOD
AT IT AND PRETTY SOON,
SHE'LL BE HAVING
ALL KINDS OF FUN.
YOU WON'T BE ABLE TO TAKE
HER SAW AWAY FROM HER.
MARY MILLER: THERE'S
AN END IN SIGHT
FOR BACKBREAKING
WORK TODAY.
CURLY: YEAH, GOOD DAY,
ALL IN ALL.
MARY MILLER: OH, I'M WHOOPED.
NARRATOR: PORT PROTECTION
ENDURES NOT BY MODERN ADVANCES
BUT BY THOSE WHO LOOK TO THE
PAST TO PRESERVE THEIR FUTURE.
TIMBI PORTER: WATCH THIS COOL
KNOT TO START IT OFF WITH,
ARE YOU READY?
HANS PORTER: SOMETIMES,
IT'S BETTER TO GO WITH
OLD-SCHOOL TECHNOLOGY.
WE CAN LEARN A LOT FROM
OUR OLD TIMERS,
THAT'S HOW WE'VE LEARNED
A LOT OURSELVES,
BY OTHER PEOPLE'S
EXPERIENCES.
TIMBI PORTER: IF I CAN TIE A
KNOT AND WIN YOUR HEART,
IT'S BEEN A GOOD DAY.
NARRATOR: THERE IS FAITH
IN TIME-HONORED METHODS,
A DETERMINATION TO KEEP
A RICH HISTORY ALIVE.
GARY MUEHLBERGER:
THE OLD TIMERS,
THOSE ARE THE GUYS THAT
THEY'RE KNOWN HERE
AND THEY CONTINUALLY COME
HOME WITH A DEER.
THEY DON'T WHINE ABOUT IT.
THEY'LL GO THERE AND HUNT
UNTIL THEY GET WHAT
THEY NEED AND THAT'S
JUST HOW IT IS.
GOOD BOY!
NARRATOR: EACH INDIVIDUAL HAS
A RESPECT FOR THOSE WHO CAME
BEFORE AND AN EAGERNESS
TO FORGE A CLEAR PATH
FOR THOSE WHO WILL SOMEDAY
TAKE THEIR PLACE.
AMANDA MAKAR: SUPER
SWEET, SAM.
SAM CARLSON: IT'S NICE TO KNOW
THAT WE STILL HAVE THAT
PIONEERING SPIRIT.
BECAUSE ONCE WE LOSE THAT,
IT'S GAME OVER.
I THINK THAT THE WORLD
WOULD BECOME A VERY
STALE PLACE IF THERE
WEREN'T PIONEERS.
NARRATOR: THIS IS
PORT PROTECTION.